wir schauen nach kasachstan wo es zu
blutigen unruhen gekommen ja kasachstan
spielt in unserem alltag selten eine
rolle dabei ist es das neuntgrößte land
der welt ehemals teil der sowjetunion
und an der grenze zu russland und china
gelegen reich an bodenschätzen und
deshalb strategisch sehr bedeutend seit
jahren gehen die menschen gegen
korruption und machtmissbrauch auf die
straße vor wenigen tagen dann die
eskalation präsident obama verlässt
einen schießbefehl laut staatsmedien
soll es über 160 tote gegeben haben über
2000 verlässt bilder von großen
demonstrationen gibt es nicht mehr immer
wieder tauchen in sozialen netzwerken
aber videos auf den schussgeräusche und
schreie zu hören sind das land ist
mittlerweile abgeriegelt aber unser
reporter paul ronzheimer ist an der
grenze zu kasachstan und mit ihm konnten
wir sprechen paul was hörst du aus dem
land
das was man aus kasachstan hört ist
weiterhin dramatisch wir stehen hier an
der grenze zwischen kirgistan und
kasachstan in den vergangenen tagen war
auch hier in der nähe immer wieder von
schüssen zu hören das was offiziell aus
dem land kommt ist umstritten man weiß
nicht ob es stimmt zumindest sagt die
regierung dass 164 menschen ums leben
gekommen sein wenn den unruhen
2200 menschen verletzt wurden und über
5400 menschen festgenommen wurden
unabhängige beobachter sind bislang
nicht wirklich rein gekommen nachdem
mattie und ist es ganz schwer zu sagen
was von diesen angaben der regierung
eben stimmt
die regierung hat einen einreise stopp
für ausländer beschlossen auch für
journalisten was bedeutet das
für ausländer auch für ausländische
journalisten wie uns gab es in den
vergangenen tagen keine möglichkeit über
diesen grenzübergang zum beispiel hinter
mir über die landgrenze zu kommen
offenbar soll es seit heute wieder
teilweise möglichkeiten per flugzeug
geben allerdings in den entscheidenden
tagen über in den vergangenen tagen
konnten ausländische journal das ist
nicht berichten nicht unabhängig
berichten und deswegen es ist so
schwierig diese angaben eben die über
die regierung kommen zu überprüfen oder
auch hintergründe zu geben was dort
wirklich passiert ist im land kasachstan
präsident hat bei wladimir putin um
unterstützung gebeten russische truppen
sind auch schon im land welche
konsequenzen hat das braucht
für vladimir putin den russischen
präsidenten ist das jetzt schon ein
riesenerfolg kasachstan war immer ein
befreundeter staat in den vergangenen
jahren natürlich allerdings wollte putin
seinen einfluss auch hier ausweiten und
jetzt sind russische truppen hier mit
dem land und die werden so schnell
wahrscheinlich nicht wieder gehen wie
wird man so schnell nicht wieder raus
bekommen das heißt präsident der
präsident konstanz konstanz präsident
ist jetzt abhängig fast von wladimir
putin und das gefällt dem russischen
präsidenten
von der deutschen regierung ist zur
krise in kasachstan bislang kaum etwas
zu hören worin liegt das paul
aus deutschland hat man tatsächlich in
den vergangenen tagen kaum etwas gehört
aus dem außenministerium hieß es von
einem staatssekretär dass die
rüstungsexporte überprüft werden die
rüstungsexperte gestoppt würden die es
nach kasachstan gegeben habe allerdings
war es gleichzeitig auch so dass
insbesondere von der europäischen union
ist dann versuche gab da zu deeskalieren
es gab telefonate mit dem kasachischen
außenminister das ist das was man
momentan versucht wohl auch weil
natürlich die augen insbesondere heute
in den nächsten tagen auf den gesprächen
zwischen russland und den amerikaner
liegen was die ukraine angeht
einschätzungen von paul ronzheimer an
der grenze zu kasachstan
russische truppen in kasachstan und
gleichzeitig auch an der grenze zur
ukraine hundert tausende russische
soldaten hat präsident putin dort
zusammengezogen übungen sind in vollem
gange und
200.000 weitere soldaten kann er
jederzeit nach lücken lassen in genf
findet heute zugleich einen usa russland
statt russland verlangt dass die ukraine
nicht in die nato eintreten kann und
droht andernfalls mit krieg in europa
für die nato und die usa natürlich eine
unannehmbare erpressung und die frage
ist was nun darüber sprechen wir mit
bild chefreporter peter thiede er ist
auf russischer seite an der grenze zur
ukraine peter guten morgen sagt uns
einmal wo du genau stehst und was du in
den vergangenen tagen in russland
recherchiert
[Musik]
und morgen an euch beide und herzlich
willkommen lisa sie stehe kurz vor mario
pohl mario pohl ist eine ukrainische
hafenstadt eine der wichtigsten
hafenstädte die es in der region gibt
und der rostov am don da kommt die don
kosaken er daher kennt man das dass es
ganz unten im südwesten russlands und
wir stehen an einer straße die die
wichtigste straße ist die lebensader
eigentlich für die für die krim ist oder
sein sollte deswegen hat wladimir putin
2040 um versucht die hafenstadt mario
pohl 77 79 kilometer weg zu erobern die
war kurz gesetzt von russischen truppen
und von separatisten ist dann wieder
frei gekämpft und man geht davon aus
sollte russland noch einmal in die ost
ukraine einfach noch einmal die ukraine
wieder offen angreifen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen wir haben ja einen
existierenden krieg dem schon 14.000
leute zum opfer gefallen sind dann würde
er sich genau diese straße hier greifen
und um mario pohl zu kriegen und eine
landverbindung zur krim zu haben darum
geht es und wir waren jetzt unterwegs
von hier unten ganz im süden bis hoch an
die an die nördliche grenze zur ukraine
bis in die region woronesch und wir
haben bedeutet dann auch gesprochen die
uns auch bestätigt haben ja es ist ganz
viel technik hierher verlegt worden es
sind soldaten hier ist kriegsgerät
zusätzlich hergebracht worden ist es
ohnehin eine aufgerüstete region und
jetzt ist zusätzlich techniker aus angst
von russland wieder überfallen zu werden
sind viele grenzübergänge von der
ukraine aus gesprengt worden oder mit
panzersperren versehen worden und russen
haben uns erzählt und auch russische
reporter die unterwegs waren haben uns
erzählt dass ihr nachts an den
bahnstrecken monate lang der strom
abgestellt worden ist immer wieder damit
niemand sieht wie wir schwere technik
hierher transportiert wird nachts auf
der eisenbahn soldaten sind aus sibirien
her verlegt von dann aus dem norden des
landes luftlande einhalten die sind 2040
hierher gebracht worden wenige kilometer
von uns entfernt ist der flugplatz tag
an druck einer der wichtigsten
militärflughafen landen normalerweise
die truppen die dann in die ukraine
einmarschiert sind damals 2014 jetzt
sind auch wieder der ganze flughafen ist
voller transportmaschinen sowohl für
technik als auch für soldaten und
übrigen von hier aus werden auch oft die
söldnertruppe die die wagen da truppen
verlegt unter anderem jetzt auch nach
kasachstan warum diese große
truppenverlegungen feder was will putin
erreichen
also hat zwei ziele er möchte einmal
wieder auf augenhöhe kommen mit den usa
wladimir putin möchte seinem volk
demonstrieren wir sind eine weltmacht
mann ist wirtschaftlich ein absoluter
zwerg und hat das motto macht das
bruttoinlandsprodukt der benelux-staaten
oder von italien also so klein ist
russland wirtschaftlich aber da man
atommacht ist kann man sich hoch
eskalieren und bekommt jetzt in genf
wieder einen gipfel mit den usa es gibt
telefonate mit joe biden das ist dass
das land die mir putin innenpolitisch
verkauft hier träumen vor allem die
älteren immer noch von der alten
sowjetunion von der weltmacht wenn es
wirtschaftlich liegt das land dann
nieder also man möchte zurück auf die
auf die weltbühne kommen und dann möchte
man verhindern dass andere länder in die
nato eintreten dass echte demokratien in
den ehemaligen sowjetstaaten entstehen
können in der ukraine hat man den
mailand damals nicht verhindern können
die aufstände die dann zur revolution
geführt haben das hat man nicht gemacht
daraus hat wladimir putin dann gelernt
er hat in belarus eingegriffen aktiv hat
lukas schenkel dort unterstützt das
macht er jetzt auch in kazan wurden
19.000 soldaten hin verlegt hat 19.000
alleine nur nach kasachstan ohne die
sondertruppen um da wirklich dass
niederzuhalten und um kein beispiel
entstehen zu lassen von demokratien von
westlich orientierten ländern in
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken und wladimir
putin hat der nato und die und den usa
12 ultimaten gestellt er möchte jetzt
ultimativ die zusage haben dass keine
anderen staaten in osteuropa in die nato
eintreten dürfen oder im umfeld
russlands und dass er entscheiden möchte
ob diese länder da eintreten dürfen oder
nicht also habe ich mir putin möchte
weiter so wie früher die großen
sowjetführer weiter über andere länder
bestimmt über andere voelker möchte
sagen können wo die sich hin entwickeln
können und diese ultimaten wird kann die
usa überhaupt nicht annehmen also das
ist unverhandelbar für den westen und
vor allem auch für die nato also werden
die usa und die nato darauf eingehen
dass auch er nein
nein also das können sie nicht und das
wäre ein verrat das wäre ein verrat an
der ukraine das wäre ein verrat an
ländern wie georgien kasachstan oder an
einen allen anderen ländern und die nato
bereitet sich ja nicht aus das ist die
erzählung die russland immer macht von
der wladimir putin liebt dass sich die
krake nato ausbreitet und nach anderen
ländern greift andersrum ist die
wahrheit die länder wollen in die nato
rein sie suchen schutz vor russland man
darf nicht vergessen weite teile zum
beispiel das gesamte weit kommt die
waren besetzt von der sowjetunion dass
die wand an die freiwillig drin die
ukraine hat die erfahrung gemacht dass
man mit russland nicht friedlich
zusammenleben kann die sind über fallen
von 2040 krieg tobt hier unweit von uns
in den sogenannten volksrepublik dann
jetzt und nur hans ja weiter hier ist
jeden tag krieg hier sterben jede woche
soldaten und die erfahrung hat die
länder gemacht putin möchte darüber
bestimmen und wenn wir mal sagen die
nato ist ein golfclub dann kann das land
die mir.de nicht entscheiden ob sein
nachbar in den golfclub kann oder nicht
rein kann das ist deswegen fehlt den
westen komplett unverhandelbar der kurze
frage noch zum schluss du bist jetzt
seit tagen in der region unterwegs was
ist dein eindruck sie merken die
menschen vor ort auf putins vorgehen
also man muss eines wissen die leute
kriegen ja 24 stunden sieben tage die
woche wirklich staatspropaganda es gibt
ja keine freien medien mehr es gibt noch
die normalisierte eine zeitung die ihr
dreimal einer woche erscheint und das
war es dann aber auch wirklich schon mit
den freien medien und die kriegen hier
die tiere die kreml propaganda rein dann
ist das eine militär region ohnehin und
da sind die leute natürlich auch
wladimir putin seite und was ich vorhin
schon gesagt habe die älteren träume mir
immer noch von der alten sonst hätten
wir haben die offiziere getroffen die
noch in der ddr gedient haben und die
uns erzählen wie schön das war damals
noch im warschauer pakt war und als mann
zusammen gegen den westen stand und das
sind die leute die rede und dann gibt es
die leute die nicht reden die sagen das
ist politik ich kümmere mich nicht um
politik und ich rede schon gar nicht mit
ausländern die leute die den kopf senken
und dann durch in alter gehen und hoffen
dass ihm nichts passiert also im großen
und ganzen wladimir putin hat hier an
einer grenze die volle unterstützung
seines volk